suite à bruxelles on va retrouver
caroline de camaret qui suit pour nous
ce sommet union européenne union
africaine avec trois défis entre
l'europe et l'afrique pour changer la
donne lors de ce sixième sommet caroline
bonsoir est-ce qu'il va vraiment
effectivement changé les liens entre
l'union européenne et les pays africains
ce sommet
en tout cas en ce moment il fait l'objet
de cet atelier thématique entre les
leaders européens et africains 27 du
côté des européens 46 du côté des
africains faut mesurer un petit peu le
rapport de force on voit toujours
l'économie mais si on regarde le
territoire l'afrique est cette fois plus
grande que le territoire de l'ue eux et
trois fois plus peuplée alors les
européens ils veulent regagner renouer
des liens de confiance ne plus être
toujours considéré comme les ex
colonisateur mais regagner des points
dans ce continent qui est maintenant
cibler par d'autres puissances comme la
chine qui a investi
énormément 20 fois plus depuis 10 ans la
russie 9 fois plus la france à peine
deux fois plus dans les dix dernières
années ça donne effectivement une notion
de la course qui est engagée pour
sensibiliser ce continent avec les
critères et les valeurs européennes avec
l'argent européen aussi toujours
premiers dannatt heures avec 150
milliards d'euros c'est énorme puisque
l'afrique en avait réclamé sur les
prochaines années
200 220 milliards donc on est on est sur
des chiffres très très haut il n'empêche
en échange de cela et bien les européens
continuent à demander des critères
démocratiques comment continuer à avoir
aussi des demandes sur les flux
migratoires et notamment la possibilité
de nouer des partenariats
holistique inclusive sur tous les sujets
l'éducation est évidemment le climat
mais aussi la possibilité de stopper
l'immigration par exemple il ya une
expérience qui est tentée au sénégal
frontex va s'installer pour essayer de
stopper les migrations dramatique vers
les canaries qui ont fait des milliers
de morts en mer et vous voyez que tout
cela doit être mis sur la table
simultanément pour recréer ce lien de
confiance avec notre premier partenaire
qui à peine à 15km de 2 du continent
européen
caroline au delà de la question
sécuritaire il ya une recherche de
solidarité en fait seulement sécuritaire
d'ailleurs au sein de ce sommet
oui on a on a beaucoup évidemment
commenté un la question malienne la
question de la lutte contre le
terrorisme qui se joue sur le territoire
de l'afrique pour que ne soit pas
importée
vers l'union européenne mais il y à
aussi évidemment en cette période de
qu'ovide la question de la santé qui est
vraiment très prégnante d'autant que 80
% des européens sont vaccinés à peine
11% des africains et là on voit bien que
les européens ont tenté quand même deux
ils ont fourni par exemple en janvier
150 millions de do c'est le plus haut
chiffre jamais atteint il espère avoir
abouti à 450 millions cet été l'afrique
a reçu aussi près de 600 millions de
doses vip sur l'initiative kovacs sont
les européens sont très sensibilisés son
donateur mais ils ont promis d'ailleurs
un milliard d'euros pour développer
développer cette industrie sur le sol
africain avec des mini usine mobile de
faveur parce qu'ils ne veulent pas levé
les brevets c'est pourtant ce que leur
demande les africains c'est une levée
des brevets qui leur permettrait
d'exploiter et bien tous les vaccins qui
ont cours et bien gratuitement et que ce
soit plus facilement distribuable mais
est bien les européens il insiste sur
les capacités de production de mettre en
place des usines et de les financer en
afrique parce qu'ils ne veulent pas et
bien désavantage est à ce point les
labos européens qui ont produit ces
brevets contre le coc vide merci
caroline caroline de camaret en direct
de bruxelles